lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
estimadas sumas y restas de números de
tres dígitos
tenemos 398 + 251 ahora este símbolo que
parece un signo de igual pero
garabateado significan que nuestro
resultado es aproximadamente igual a es
decir vamos a hacer una estimación
normalmente diría pausa el vídeo pero
esta vez quiero que lo intentes
mentalmente voy a dejar de hablar por
tres segundos y quiero ver si puedes
darme el resultado ojo el punto aquí es
que este mes el resultado no que me des
el resultado exacto
bien suponiendo que ya lo intentaste
ahora voy a decirte cómo lo pensé claro
que podemos tomar un papel y resolver
esta operación o tal vez puedas
encontrar la respuesta exacta en tu
mente pero en la vida diaria si estamos
en un mercado y algo cuesta 398 pesos y
otra cosa cuesta 251 pesos
aproximadamente cuánto tendrías que
pagar si te llevas a ambos objetos bueno
en mi mente me lo pienso de la siguiente
manera 398 es aproximadamente igual a
400 si redondeamos a la decena más
cercana o debería decir a la centena más
cercana en el caso de 398 la centena más
cercana es 400 y ahora 251 si lo
redondeamos a la decena más cercana es
aproximadamente igual a 250 por lo tanto
si sumas estas dos cantidades obtienes
650 que para nuestra suerte es el inciso
t
bien ahora vamos a ver el resultado
exacto y así veremos qué tan lejos
estábamos del resultado que estimamos si
realizamos 398 + 251 tengo 8 + 1 es 99 5
es 14 ponemos el 4 y agrupamos el 1 como
una centena y por último 1 3236 en este
caso en particular observan estamos muy
cerca de nuestra estimación y como
estamos estimando si obtenemos el
resultado exacto está bien es parte de
lo que nos piden bien hagamos otro
ejemplo aquí tengo que hacer una resta
así que para os el vídeo intenta
encontrar el resultado aproximando tan
rápido como puedas a que es
aproximadamente igual 678 menos 273
bien hagámoslo juntos aquí hay un par de
formas de resolverlo
la primera es redondear a la decena más
cercana en cuyo caso 678 es
aproximadamente igual observa si lo
redondea a la decena siguiente es 680
menos 270 y esto será igual a bueno
600 menos 200 es 480 menos 70 es 10
así que 410 y esta es una forma de
hacerlo
la otra es redondear lo a la centena más
cercana y decir 678 es aproximadamente
igual a 700 si lo redondeamos a la
centena más cercana y 273 es
aproximadamente igual a 300 si lo
redondeamos a la centena más cercana
aunque estos menos exactos tenemos ya
una aproximación de 400
y aún así son respuestas similares ahora
en ambas formas de estimar ya sea a la
decena más cercana oa la centena más
cercana llegamos a algo cercano a 400
que es el inciso a la razón del por qué
tenemos que resolver muchos ejercicios
de estimaciones es porque aunque cada
quien obtienen una estimación diferente
esta estimación debe ser una estimación
razonable que esté cerca de la respuesta
correcta me despido seguiremos en el
siguiente